it's been said that every kid has a bug
period, you know when you're
nine or ten, you bring home spiders
and all sorts of creepy crawlies in jars and so on,
and I had a bug and period but I never grew
out of it.
And I was just delighted to find as I
got older that
there're careers in science working on bugs
and one thing led to another.
I've been at Harvard for fifty one years,
I came as a graduate student,
and during that period of time I've worked
on a wide variety of subjects
many of them pivoted on the study of ants.
First of all from ants we've learned an
awful lot about basic biology
for example, how they communicate
almost exclusively with chemicals
this is such a different world, it's almost
the kind of world you would imagine
on another planet
how these social creatures communicate, not through
words, sounds,
not by the vision,
but by letting out different
odors
to communicate messages.
they've taught us that. We've learned a lot about
the origin of altruism and cooperation
in evolution.
That's one level.
The second level would be
what can they teach us
about our, the proper conduct of
our own societies,
and the answer has got to be
nada
zilch
nothing. We don't want to live like ants.
First of all they are the most war like of all animals,
colonies are always fighting.
And second of course as everyone knows they're
highly subordinated
to the communal
activities
there are no three freedoms, or no
bill of rights, there's nothing.
Because they are programmed
you know, to act so closely together
and I like to say just to tweak
my Marxist friends that
Karl Marx
Karl Marx was right
he just had the wrong species.
My most recent work,
and the great deal of my time and energy have
gone into
the exploration of the world's biological diversity
which we now understand is mostly unknown,
particularly in the small creatures like
insects and bacteria.
I would say more than ninety percent
of the species haven't even been discovered
but we're also learning and beginning to put
a measure on
a very
fats and accelerating rate
of extinction
of those species. We're wiping out a large part
of biodiversity/
I'm on the board of directors
or advisory boards of
most of the large contributing organizations
the ones that deal with
the global environment
So I've been very much involved in
laying plans to
to save as much
of the world's ecosystems as possible
and most particularly
in the developing countries
that have tropical forest, coral reefs, and other
biologically rich environments
and I'm optimistic that
before too long we can develop were world wide
strategies
that will save a large part of the world's
remaining biological diversity